[Music]  Brandi Glanville makes her red carpet  debut with her new man a businessman at  DJ priests it's date night debut of the  new man how you feelin okay I need to  know the love story here how did we meet  how long have we been going out no no  information there but I'm just very  nervous this is a tender love connection  and things are going good have we said I  love you yet or anything all the good  stuff all the good stuff yes absolutely  and have the boys met him but introduced  yeah and they've taken a liking to you  absolutely everything's been very good  yeah could you have you see you're  glowing and I know then know the nerve  but the nerves are because it's real and  you're protecting it this is the first  like big real relationship since not  gonna fill you with any more questions  go in there have fun get a drink take  your xanax  you  [Music]